son las imágenes del día en Estados
Unidos es Memphis 7 de enero y cinco
policías dan una paliza a tairi Nichols
un joven de 29 años que murió tres días
después por las heridas provocadas sus
últimas palabras fueron mamá entre
gritos desesperados
pero para mí descubrir que mi hijo me
estaba llamando y yo estaba solo unos
metros de distancia ni siquiera lo
escuché no tiene ni idea de lo que
siento en este momento ni idea
el vídeo fue publicado por las
instituciones de Memphis un día después
de que los cinco ex policías fuesen
acusados de asesinato en segundo grado
asalto secuestro Mala conducta oficial y
opresión cargos tan solo Tres semanas
después del incidente la policía alegó
que fue detenido por conducción
imprudente pero la violenta reacción de
los agentes no está Clara
no sabemos qué pasó Así que no podemos
pretender o imaginar lo sucedido todo lo
que sabemos Es que la cantidad de fuerza
que se aplicó en esa situación fue
excesiva
un 65% de la población de Memphis es
afroamericana por lo que se produjeron
memoriales y concentraciones durante
todo el viernes la familia de Nichols y
el presidente Joe biden pidieron marchas
pacíficas
habla mucho de la imagen de Estados
Unidos por lo que está en juego ver si
somos el país que decimos que somos es
decir país de Ley y orden y medios por
los cuales podemos protestar
pacíficamente y dejar que los tribunales
tomen su decisión
Nicole había participado en 2020 en el
movimiento de las vidas negras importan
con las mayores protestas anti racistas
en décadas tras la muerte violenta manos
de la policía de George Floyd en 2020